[Música]
estados unidos y rusia buscan
acercamientos para aliviar las tensiones
en ucrania y anuncian la organización de
una cumbre en enero moscú exige que la
otan detenga su expansión hacia el este
de europa y washington and pide
garantías de que no habrá agresiones
contra quién
méxico promete dejar de exportar
petróleo a partir de 2023 para abastecer
su mercado interno el gobierno cree que
así ayudará a lograr la autosuficiencia
y controlar el alza constante en el
precio de los combustibles hablamos con
un experto
récord de casos de kobe 19 en varios
países del mundo francia reino unido de
españa y china reportan cifras de
contagios no vistas desde el inicio de
la pandemia sudamérica pasó de ser uno
de los epicentros de casos al líder en
vacunación
bienvenidos a una nueva actualización de
noticias en francés 24 los saluda daniel
hablando
comenzamos con eeuu porque funcionarios
de ese país y los de rusia participarán
en conversaciones sobre seguridad el 10
de enero para tratar de aliviar las
tensiones en ucrania el encuentro se
producirá tras semanas de intensas
tensiones entre los países por las
acusaciones estadounidenses de que moscú
planeó una invasión al país vecino el
presidente joe biden no descarto
encontrarse personalmente con su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin
una preparación constante con un
objetivo claro cerca de kiev el ejército
ucraniano se entrena para enviar un
mensaje contundente a rusia acusada de
querer invadir el país nosotros yo
durante 8 años he vivido con la idea de
que hasta que no le demos una buena
bofetada a rusia no nos dejarán en paz
siempre acaban con los débiles y si no
nos defendemos esta invasión nos
mantendrá abajo durante mucho tiempo
moscú niega rotundamente las acusaciones
pero dice sentirse amenazada y al
parecer ha concentrado casi 100.000
soldados en la frontera ucraniana en las
últimas semanas diez mil habrían sido
retirados a sus bases el sábado hacia el
kremlin está presionando abiertamente
para impedir cualquier ampliación de la
otan en ucrania o en los antiguos países
soviéticos en medio de la creciente
tensión estados unidos y rusia
confirmaron que se reunirán el próximo
10 de enero en donde moscú reiterará sus
peticiones
en cuanto a lo que queremos creo que
también lo comentamos muchas veces esta
es una propuesta seria queremos ante
todo garantías serias de eeuu y de la
otra mons
washington por su parte ve con optimismo
el encuentro
eeuu espera a comprometerse con rusia
cuando nos sentamos a hablar rusia podrá
poner sus preocupaciones sobre la mesa y
nosotros pondremos las nuestras
incluyendo sus actividades un diálogo
directo al que le seguirán otros
encuentros a través de la otan el 2 de
enero y después en la ofc la
organización para la seguridad y la
cooperación en europa así washington
intentará explorar todos los canales
diplomáticos para persuadir a moscú
y en noticias de américa latina' el
gobierno de méxico anunció que la
estatal pemex la petrolera más endeudada
del mundo dejará de exportar petróleo a
partir de 2023 el objetivo es destinar
todo el crudo producido a la refinación
local para abastecer el mercado y evitar
las importaciones de esta manera también
busca controlar la histórica alza de
precios de los combustibles hablamos
sobre el tema con arturo carranza
analista y experto en temas energéticos
señor arturo muy buenas noches solo en
la primera quincena de diciembre los
precios de los combustibles subieron más
del 12% qué tan viable entonces
considera esta propuesta para frenar
esos aumentos y porque cree que se está
tomando justo ahora
a nivel nacional daniela habló en el
caso de méxico hay serias dudas con
respecto a lograr lo que el gobierno
nacional considera la autosuficiencia
energética esto es producir el petróleo
crudo necesario para procesarlo y
producir gasolinas que abastezcan en
mente el mercado nacional veis serias
dudas con respecto a este objetivo de
autosuficiencia
porque actualmente la producción de
petróleo crudo asciende a un millón
seiscientos mil barriles diarios y el
gobierno plantea llevar la producción a
2 millones de barriles diarios para
lograr la autosuficiencia
por otro lado también plantea elevar la
producción de refinados que actualmente
están en niveles de 500 mil barriles
diarios de petrolíferos y se
necesitarían llevarlos a un nivel
aproximado de 800 mil barriles diarios
de petrolíferos todo esto en el plazo de
tres años por lo mismo con un recomentó
hay serias dudas con respecto a que se
alcance el objetivo de autosuficiencia
energética
ahora hablando en temas económicos cómo
puede una petrolera como pemex que
atraviesa por serios problemas
financieros dejar de exportar petróleo
estos días rentable para la empresa
daniela con respecto a este
planteamiento también existen serias
dudas sobre la viabilidad de la
propuesta de que petróleos méxicanos
deje de exportar petróleo crudo y el
gobierno de mexico deje de ingresar
recursos por el concepto de exportación
de petróleo en este sentido actualmente
petróleo mexicano se está exportando en
promedio un millón de barriles diarios
de petróleo lo que implica financiar el
gasto público en un 14 por ciento si
petróleos méxicanos deja de exportar
petróleo el gasto público tendría que
buscar otras fuentes de financiamiento
para suplir ese 14% restante y
actualmente no hay un planteamiento para
sustituir el 14% de los ingresos
petroleros por lo mismo quedan serias
dudas con respecto a cómo se podría
materializar esta propuesta de dejar de
exportar petróleo para producir
gasolinas y consumirlas en el mercado
nacional pues señor arturo carranza
muchas gracias por su análisis y
seguimos en mexico pero para hablar esta
vez de la pandemia del coronavirus
porque en medio de la amplia propagación
mundial de la nueva variante omicron el
gobierno de ese país aseguró que no la
ve como una amenaza esta nación acumula
39 millones de casos y se acerca a las
300.000 muertes la cuarta cifra más alta
del mundo mientras omicron originó la
suspensión de fiestas en europa así como
la cancelación de cientos de vuelos en
eeuu méxico tuvo unas fiestas sin
restricciones
ciertamente se han encontrado casos de
reinfección pero no parece ser lo más
predominante de la variante o micro es
muy importante no perder de vista esta
información porque con frecuencia se
sobreestima la participación de la
variante o micro como hemos dicho desde
al menos octubre de este año es
indiscutible que en algún momento en
méxico así como ha ocurrido en otros
países puede haber una cuarta ola y es
que sudamérica es la región del mundo
con la mayor tasa de vacunación contra
el cob y 19 son datos que entrega el
proyecto our world in their ad y que
llegan justo cuando se registran récords
de contagios en varias zonas del mundo
sudamérica cuenta con el 63 3 por ciento
de su población con el esquema completo
de vacunación por delante de europa en
donde la cifra es del 67 por ciento de
sus habitantes en norteamérica el 57 7
por ciento de las personas tiene el
esquema completo frente al 50 y 54 por
ciento de asia mientras que en áfrica
solamente el 88 por ciento de los ciudad
tiene su carta de inmunización completa
seguimos hablando de pandemia hoy nuevos
récords de contagios de kobe de 19 se
registraron en varios países del mundo
en medio de la rápida expansión de la
variante omicron francia reportó 179 mil
807 casos en las últimas 24 horas una de
las cifras diarias más altas de todo el
mundo y la mayor en europa desde el
inicio de la pandemia
reino unido por su parte dijo haber
tenido 129 mil 471 contagios el martes
la cifra más alta desde el inicio de la
pandemia que no incluye a escocia
irlanda del norte el reporte de surge de
un día después de que el ministro primer
ministro boris johnson descartar a
introducir nuevas restricciones en
inglaterra para evitar la propagación
del virus
en españa los nuevos casos de kobe 19 se
acercaron a los 100.000 en las últimas
24 horas es un nuevo récord que lleva a
más de 6 millones la cifra de contagios
en un país en el que el 90% de la
población ya ha recibido la pauta
completa de vacunación las autoridades
regionales están reforzando medidas de
cara a las celebraciones de fin de año
y cerramos con noticias de jordania en
donde a golpes terminó una sesión del
parlamento en la que se debatía sobre
igualdad de género era una sesión
televisada que estalló cuando se comenzó
a debatir una enmienda a la constitución
que agregaba la palabra jordana para
referirse a las ciudadanas en un
capítulo que garantiza la igualdad de
derechos entre hombres y mujeres algunos
parlamentarios calificaron la
modificación de inútil lo que generó
riñas con los simpatizantes de la
propuesta y obligó a suspender el debate
hasta que es informativo quédense con
los otros
[Música]